for those of you who've been following
my channel for a while you'll know that
i usually start my videos with some sort
of gag
joke or meme but after watching
netflix's catla i was
honestly left speechless i never thought
an ending could be simultaneously
beautiful and ugly the worst part about
it is no one i know has seen the show or
even heard about it for that matter
and don't get me wrong this isn't a 10
out of 10 amazing show that you should
go out and start watching immediately
in fact i found it rather slow at points
but the last episode is just
so crazy and moving and scary
it made me feel so many conflicting
emotions i just had to talk about it i
don't say this liberally but catlett
could be the craziest ending i've
covered on my channel and i'm excited to
discuss it with you
even if it's just for my own sanity and
if you like what i'm putting down please
consider
liking and subscribing when i first
watched the trailer for katla i was
hooked it's basically one of those slow
burning foreign crime dramas like
broadchurch but with a sci-fi twist dead
people covered in ash from a local
volcano start reappearing in the small
icelandic town of vic who are these
people why is it happening
and do these resurrected beings who by
the way have all the memories
of their past selves making them
essentially clones have more
nefarious motives i'm going to start
with the final episode and i'll do my
best to explain
what's going on even if you haven't seen
the show the last episode is titled
i am you and why they decided to call it
this will soon become evident
it opens on mikhail the eight-year-old
son of darian raquel who back at the end
of episode 2 mysteriously reappeared to
his father the catch the real mikael
died three years ago
dari a scientist doesn't believe this is
their son
even though he looks exactly like him
and has all his memories
raquel wanting her son back believes
this is a second
chance but over the course of the season
we'll see that mikhail has a dark side
he struggles with mental illness so bad
that he cuts off the wings of a pet
parrot sets fire to a school hoping that
his schoolmates will burn inside
and eventually cuts the throat of a
woman trying to help him with a
box cutter in one of the most
heartbreaking scenes of the series
raquel
abandons her son in the middle of
nowhere she is overwhelmed
is this really her son and if so what do
you do with a child who is filled with
violent thoughts and acts them out
without a shred of remorse
he ends up making his way back to his
parents where they decide to do the
unthinkable but we'll get to that in a
bit in episode 7
dari investigates the glacier near the
volcano the place where these clones
seem to originate way back in episode 1
he picked up mysterious readings from
the samples given to him and
now he wants to investigate personally
he's also been inundated with local folk
tales of reappearing townspeople called
changelings and these date back to the
1300s the reappearances coincide with
the eruptions of the katla volcano and
there's a reason for this
as dory continues his investigation he
realizes that the
reason his samples are picking up
unexplainable readings
is that they contain material not of
this world he theorizes that hundreds of
thousands of years ago
a meteor hit the volcano and when it
erupts
small pieces of it are brought to the
surface and fall on the glacier
dari says to his wife
according to dari these clones are
manifestations of their trauma this
mikhail isn't their son he's a copy sent
to help them deal with their trauma of
losing their child
at the beginning of the season dari and
raquel are going through a divorce
likely a result of the loss of their
child neither of them have gotten
over this loss and it eats away at their
relationship it's only when mikhail
comes back do they realize their son
is gone for good luck
[Music]
and in one of the most insane things
i've seen on tv in a while
dari and raquel drown their son or
should i say the
copy of it metaphorically they are
drowning their trauma
they are getting over the death of their
child by killing their child
the whole thing is wild and when they do
the deed for the first time dari
and raquel embrace it's simultaneously
tragic yet hopeful with the revelation
that the reappearing people are
manifestations of trauma it puts the
other character's experiences into
perspective
episode 1 begins with the reappearance
of gun hilda the odd thing about her is
that she believes
it's the year 2001. even weirder is that
the real gunhilda
20 years older is still alive in sweden
they are copies but one is 20 years
younger and there is a reason for this
20 years ago gunhilda was impregnated by
a man named thor
she wanted to get rid of it but due to a
botched procedure
ended up injuring her child who grew up
deformed or at least that's what she's
thought for the last 20 years
she's been living with this guilt or
trauma that she's harmed her child she
then overcompensates by being overly
protected of him by the way the actor
who plays the son
bjorn is one of the skarsgard brothers
gunhilda's manifestation
comes back as a 20 year old younger
version of herself to prove that it
wasn't her botched surgery that injured
the child it was
genetic she can finally let go of all
that pain that's been bogging her down
all these years we also have gizly the
town's police
officer his wife reappears but unlike
his actual wife who is hooked up to a
respirator dying of lung cancer
this one is perfectly normal he believes
it's a sign from god and
ends up switching his real life's cancer
pills with placebos
to make her die faster so that he can be
with this new
version but i like to think this
manifestation isn't here for gizly she's
here for his wife magna to help her
accept her own death
whereas before miagna lived in pain with
a husband who almost
assaults her hooked up to a respirator
unable to move and living with cancer
with the arrival of her clone she
accepts death the magna clone ends up
taking the real one to die
head first into the volcano and we can
see this is what the real one
wants it's death on her own terms
finally we have grima
she has so much trauma that she has two
copies help
one of her dead sister alsa and two of
herself
and these are done for very different
reasons at the beginning of the series
grima is in a bad place she hasn't
gotten over the death of her sister over
a year ago
refuses to leave the desolate island and
is in a loveless marriage her husband
jarten still cares for her but grima has
walled herself off at the end of episode
1 grima's sister
mysteriously reappears ausa was grima's
older sister who struggled with
alcoholism likely the result of watching
her own mother kill herself by
drowning she went missing a year ago
when katla erupted elsa
also caught her father thor cheating on
her mother with gun hilda it's good
writing how all these things
weave together to create believable
motivations for our characters so grima
has a lot of trauma she hasn't gotten
over the death of her sister or
even her mother for that matter
this has put a strain on her
relationships mostly her marriage
so when elsa reappears it gives her a
chance to say goodbye
and vent those feelings and emotions she
was never able to express
it gives her something she was never
able to have closure
this is encapsulated when she gives
ausa's clone the actual dna results
taken from her dead body that was
uncovered in episode 4
an exact match a woman who refused to
believe her sister was dead
by clinging to the hope she could still
be out there now watches as the clone
drowns herself in the water the same way
their mother did it's
eerily poetic the ausa clone has served
her purpose
and thus throws herself in the sea but
there's still one clone that lingers an
exact
copy of grima at the end of episode 5
grima finds a copy of herself this copy
is everything she
isn't or should i say everything grima
used to be
caring affectionate hopeful a good
partner
grima even wonders if she's the
changeling the clone is who she used to
be and
she's the one who's actually changed and
that's exactly why this
guima has appeared to hold a mirror to
her to show her what has happened to her
and her relationships you'll notice a
lot of mere symbolism
incorporated here this karima clone
lives a great loving life because she
has
forgiven her mother for killing herself
gotten over the death of her sister
and doesn't take her husband's love for
granted perhaps grima can have a life
like this too
if she can get over her trauma the two
groomers decide to play russian roulette
to see
who will stay and the scene is shot in
such a way that when one of them
actually dies we aren't sure who it is
take a look at this shot the korima
clone is on the left with the blue top
while the
original is on the right however the
camera will sometimes cut to a
reflection in a mirror where the
positions are reversed
this makes keeping track of who is who
very tricky so i went and counted the
order
and noticed something very sneaky here
it is and remember that this gun
only has six chambers real grima fake
real fake then real but just before the
fifth shot goes off it cuts to a pitcher
of
fake crema i'll let it play out here and
watch as the beige top turns into the
blue top
after the second cut
it throws the entire back and forth off
we can't count anything that's happening
here as the truth considering the
manipulation both in
editing and via reflections i think the
creators want this ambiguity of us
guessing who really survived regardless
the final six shot
looks as though it's the grima with the
blue top aka the clone but i wanna hear
what you guys think in the comments
below
in the next scene we see the surviving
grima happy with her family as the dead
grima is buried in the ash outside
i'd like to believe that this is the
real grima who's gotten over her trauma
and become what the fake
grima wanted her to be but i guess we'll
never know
we also see bjorn here with thor his
father i'd like to think that they can
forge a father-son relationship gisley
after failing to capture his wife or
should i say wives
asks for forgiveness from god the funny
thing here is that earlier in the season
one of the characters remarks that this
painting of jesus
looks a lot like thor who is a god in
norse mythology
the final shots are of deep within the
glacier of more copies stirred by
another blast of the volcano
either this is the show's way of hinting
at a season two or perhaps it's a nod
that trauma is a constant
trauma happens but we're the ones who
have to decide whether to face it and
move on or let it fester
overall iceland's first original is as
striking as iceland itself
it's a portrait much like the land it's
filmed on eerily
beautiful i'm hoping more people will
get to check this show out it may not be
everyone's cup of tea
but its ending certainly will have
people talking
speaking of which let me know what you
thought about katla below
i'm interested in your thoughts and
theories thanks for watching everyone
please be sure to like and subscribe
every little bit helps the channel out
and for more bad takes you can also
follow me on twitter and instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much